I mean they're following it like the
beginning of the end well season seven
be the last time the Pretty Little Liars
get a messages the stars are dishing on
the series finale rumors and hinting at
a spinoff this is definitely the most
romantic season and it's also the most
deadly so you guys are in for a lot of
surprises there's a lot of drama but
it's also I think the fans are going to
enjoy it so if it is our last season
it's still gonna be magical do you think
this is the last season I mean we have
been told this is the end as we know it
of PLL as we know it so that's the only
verbiage I was given no I think it's a
juggernaut you know and I think it's not
gonna die completely I don't know which
direction it's gonna go in but yeah the
best way to describe it is it's probably
the last season with a full path which
is what's made it you know what it is so
it's a little bittersweet you know I may
continue in some way shape or form with
new people or keep some of the caps I
don't know yet but you know long-lived
PLL
Troian Bellisario is already feeling the
farewell emotions on set no matter what
the scene is and it wasn't really even
having to do with the contents of the
scene it was that I looked into Keegan's
eyes and I realized I was like oh my god
like I've known you for seven years
really it was it was a thought that like
if we don't continue in a certain
capacity like is this is this part of my
life is done this is my relationship
with this person even though like we'll
see each other we'll still be friends
but like we won't see each other as
often we won't be guaranteed to see each
other and I was just like I mean in a
way it's like you're looking at your
boyfriend or like one of your best
friends your work boyfriend it is
eventually if you're very much yeah my
work hubby